une fumée âcre en lisière de forêt les
secours ont très vite repérer le lieu du
crash ce matin en vain car à leur
arrivée les trois victimes présentes
dans l'avion était déjà décédé dans les
villages alentour plusieurs habitants
bien entendu le passage du monomoteur un
peu après 10 heures bah déjà ce bris
proximité de moteurs d'avions qu'on
n'entend jamais aussi proche
et puis plus rien plus aucun bruit d'un
seul coup et après ce bruit de ferraille
cet homme a vu tomber l'avion c'est lui
qui a prévenu les secours
je les ai vu traverser la couche
nuageuse enfin il restait 100 m par
rapport aux soldes quoi grosso modo
entre le bois des nuages et puis puis le
sol y avait une centaine de mètres et
j'ai vu qu'il a essayé de tirer le
parachute de secours et puis et puis
puis voilà le crash sans ni suivi puis
la fumée l'explosion et puis voilà
contre l'islam on peut rien faire quoi
il aurait fallu orange aurait fallu
faire quoi le parachute de secours
destinés à l'avion a bien eu le temps de
se déployer un élément important pour
les enquêteurs spécialistes des
accidents aériens venus de mulhouse et
de roissy car pour le reste cet accident
interroge l'avion devait se poser à
moins de deux kilomètres de là sur
l'aérodrome de la vèze voilà donc ce
retrait celle assez bizarre bon y'a de
la brume ya du brouillard
il était en phase d'approché il est en
phase d' approche de l'aérodrome et ce
qu'ils ont envoyé un message de secours
d'appels ou de l'apparemment détresse
non non non le dernier contact était un
contact serein l'avion un cirrus 22
taillé pour les lots trajet était parti
de caen en normandie vers 8h ce matin à
bord une femme et deux hommes
on ne connaît pas encore leur identité
mais on sait qu'il y avait un couple de
retraités ce soir les enquêteurs sont
toujours sur place pour comprendre la
trajectoire malheureuse de cet avion qui
n'étaient pas dotés de boîtes noires